[Music]
welcome back to the truejoy youtube
channel uh we're gonna do a few of these
little podcasts like mini pods sometimes
we discuss doing the true news and uh
yeah maybe the news is a little bit old
or it doesn't feel quite as hot or it's
not as funny as you think it is sure
another chinwag as well sometimes but
also uh
i think uh it's good to keep the sort of
podcast for interviews and then just to
do some random ass podcasts for the
people right this is for the people this
is just yeah this is for the culture of
podcasting in the uk you're welcome as
if every other podcast hasn't already
discussed this will smith slapped
another man and not just any man
chris rock one of the greatest comedians
of all time generational probably the
guy who got me to fall in love with
stand-up comedy was chris rock actually
i know he was influenced by a whole load
of other people eddie murphy and richard
pryor but chris rock was the first one
that i saw where i was like i need to
watch every single stand-up you've ever
done yeah uh there was um never scared
bigger black uh uh raw and uncut all of
them type of um i think raw was eddie
sorry yeah but you know i was obsessed
with watching him and uh yeah he's so
likable that kind of proves the point he
sort of got you into it and then after
that you were like yeah and i'm gonna go
and watch everyone else who does
something similar to this basically yeah
yeah um because it's also it's fair to
say that he also pioneered um a certain
kind of comedy that was a little bit
different because before that comedians
were much more like
and then he was like
and you're just like oh wow he came up
um like i i could literally verbati um
like do his like
don't because i think that'll mean you
say some quite offensive things if it
comes out of your mouth no but like
skeet skeet skate right like you know um
it's kanye west uh well yeah it is now
but like um
great opening great closing yeah you
know there's so many lines uh and
weirdly we went to say will smith this
year
and it was funny when we dropped that
podcast i was like not really sure this
is really relevant for people anymore
and all of a sudden they'll say this is
highly relevant that might be getting
some clicks though yeah and what we're
doing is saying nice things about will
and how much we love watching him
because
he is an icon right uh
and someone we grew up watching
but we
we there was an incident where obviously
everyone knows what happened by now
a silly little joke about you know
jada could
act in the next gi j and movie because
she's got short hair and they're all no
little to know how yeah
and therefore you know j i j and always
play as a [__] it's a shaven-headed
woman but he's in the army look as it
happens
a lot of details have come out since
then
chris rock didn't write that joke it was
written by someone in the back who you
know
chris rock doesn't write all of his own
jokes sure
and this is this is this doesn't make
that this doesn't mean that he isn't
responsible for what came out of his
mouth i mean he said it but i'm just
saying interestingly he didn't actually
write the joke
and
um he was unaware
that
jada had alopecia
not a happy home life
so weird how prince
words come back um but
it's it's
she's had short hair for years
forever yeah i can't really think of a
time where i like if i think of her i
think of short hair absolutely so
you know um you could be it could be
quite easy for anyone and not know that
i mean and that's also a style amongst a
lot of if i'd say black women like a lot
of black women wear their hair short
because it's easier it's nice as well
it's amazing it's a good look and i
think when women can pull that off it
proves like you know you've got to be a
certain level of woman to do that right
or amber rose amber rose made it hard to
be fair she was sexy as [__] but back in
the day yeah um but this is the thing is
even when we went to see will smith
the whispers in the audience the
narrative was hmm he never mentioned
the marriage right the situation with
jada he didn't even acknowledge jada
existed and this was a show
all about his [__] life story so his
kids were involved his acting was
involved she was the only person not
mentioned now if she is that important
you to think he didn't mention that why
didn't he mention her because that was
the elephant in the room that they have
a [__] up relationship we all know it
and it's unfortunately see i want to
unpack all this every sentence i want to
pick up it's spilled out into the oscars
the jerry springer situation that they
are living behind closed doors
is now blue it's public it's everything
right will took the [__] on stage did he
pretty much that as well wow you know
what i'm saying that would be more like
in the middle of the oscars and
i've never wanted to be famous in my
life
until now you wanted to be at those
because now i'm like oh like if i'm
famous enough i could just walk and slap
any [__] i'm pretty sure you're up
chris rock's not a [__] first no but i
could slap anyone i want and then get on
stage get an award cry people applaud me
life is good
you get forgiven i honestly think that's
part of it if he hadn't have won the
best actor award that night
that
it basically you basically go
right well
sorry this changes everything i also
think that because it's will smith right
and he
is like a childhood like weirdo yeah we
loved him growing up and he's just sort
of part of the fabric of entertainment
now and then played an action hero who
we're just sort of used to him slapping
people or doing them yeah
i was sat there thinking that was better
than any punch you threw in the alley
movie because that was one of the i'm a
huge muhammad ali fan one of the worst
movies i've ever seen in my life right
mental like international
in terms of it was every aspect of it
like boxing wise like it was not a good
boxing film it was terrible yeah i loved
independence they loved men in black ali
very similar to ali trash movie it was
wow west
it was written as if like let's just get
the good bits like this there was just
no set up sure and like you're like
who is malcolm x here right like you're
just supposed to gather that that guy's
malcolm like they just
doesn't work yeah
sorry there are so many plot holes
there's just so much i want to cover so
what were you thinking when you first
seen it
i thought it was staged when i first saw
it and a little bit of me thought um
because
we've heard about the oscars in recent
years viewing figures are dropping
people are getting a lot more like oh
the oscars who really cares sort of
thing there's a lot of cultural
irrelevance about it because it doesn't
feel relevant to pop culture anymore
they're so removed from us right the
regular people and i think that is
actually what we've seen in will smith's
actions yeah it's just how distant it
feels oh okay see i want to kind of
unpack that i'll finish my oscars point
but i really want to unpack whether this
is them being removed or whether this is
will smith actually being a very human
person and
vice versa i think the oscars is
desperate for views so i when i saw that
i went oh you've staged something a bit
weird there where will smith walks up
and you see chris rock as he walks over
going huh
do you know what i thought he thought
was coming and and this would have been
way better by the way yeah i thought
will was going to like get him get a
little yeah
and then maybe bring br bring bring up
bring him over jade angle say
because that's the will smith we know
the will smith we know is the guy who
will out banter you humiliate you make
jokes about you
because the guy was the life and soul of
tv every part yeah and not only that but
like he was you know i think i think he
felt like the chosen one because the
story that we heard on the night was you
know there were some prominent people
who went will this is your opportunity
be the fresh prince of bel-air do this
do this do this and he took the
opportunity with both hands so he felt
anointed by some of the older guys
within that community and when that
happens but how could you not feel like
the chosen one you you literally were
the biggest movie star in the world yeah
so you changed the game yeah the this
this was the like i know denzel had you
know had
a bit of a part in this great yeah
denzel had a great career and denzel is
that smart old man in all of this but
but the point was will went beyond him
in terms of commercial success right
will became the box office
star which is what films have become and
partly why the oscars has begun to feel
a little bit irrelevant to film it's
still relevant to film lovers but not to
pop culture in the same way like at one
point those two were one and the same
will smith is probably one of those
bridges right yeah and that's what the
thing that really pissed me off was i
saw the memes about it before i thought
that saw the [__] clip i wanted to
see the clip first and then the memes if
twitter can fix this where i see what
the actual news is and then the reaction
to the news it'll be better than if i'm
watching it having seen her so so
so okay so so
let's let's try and unpack this as it
happened right
you've got
jada clearly not finding the joke funny
right which is her prerogative
but will clearly laughing
clearly
right but clearly but right with that
let's unpack it stage by stage chris
rock tells the joke the audience all
react with a
sort of thing but there's clearly like
uh-huh you know it's funny but it's not
funny funny do you know what i mean and
it's also not side splitting the
hilarious the point
it's a shitty one the point we wouldn't
go do we drop that because that just
seems a little do we need but will was
laughing will was laughing but then that
reminded me of this point in the show uh
that he did with idris elba that we're
going to reference a lot because it's my
only reference for will smith really
he went i'm a bit of a people pleaser
you know i like for people to i like to
feel for people to feel comfortable i
like to please people so i imagine as
will smith you're sort of going what's
the thing here he's a comedian i'll play
along i laugh we all laugh together
yeah very good that's sort of his
personality do you know what i mean
jade is not that personality's effective
i mean
that's the one thing that we said in our
podcast post going to see will smith was
jada clearly has has left a black mark
on his life to a degree where you know
at one point this was a couple in love
and now it's an extremely dysfunctional
situation where they're sort of trying
to keep going
but the whole world can see it
like
i i felt like we we're going all over
here but one thing that really came away
from that
we've got to say wilson talk about his
life for an hour in person close enough
to touch him we learn you know you and i
are pretty good at working things out
about people and i just felt like i was
looking at a man in his early 50s he was
struggling to come to terms with the
fact that he was getting older
hollywood had moved on you know they've
got the rock now they've got other
people now
and he had been publicly shamed and
embarrassed by
um a situation where his wife decided
because she doesn't have the career he
does and she wanted her own thing
despite what a lot of people have been
saying about her calling her an icon i'm
sorry what the [__] like every role
she's ever had is off the back of him
pretty much from a long long [__] 20
[__] years right
and
she'd started a podcast where she
dragged this guy on and got
her dirty laundry out so that she could
get the attention she could get the
views and she could be seen a certain
way
will smith isn't going on any other talk
show to admit this [__] right no money
is going to get him to do that he did
that to make her position stronger as a
favor for her and he sat there and i'm
being honest like a bit of a [__] and
took it right and it felt like this was
a man taking his medicine for what a
[__] up relationship he was in to try
and appease her and when i seen his
actions at the grammys when you see him
go from laughing at the oscars sorry
yeah it cuts away
you're seeing chris on stage it cuts
right back will's out of his chair on
his way to slap the guy and you're like
what happened in that time well what i
think happened is he clocked that she
was unhappy and thought
if i do nothing and as she's publicly
emasculated him by comparing him to men
who are more masculine in tupac and in
others he probably thought if i don't
act now a i'm a [__] in her eyes and b
i'll never hear the [__] end of this
because chris rock had previously made a
joke a few years back for those who
don't remember
2016-17 where uh jade had i'm i'm not
going to the oscars it doesn't publicly
it doesn't represent uh black people
enough and chris rock got on stage and
said
you know that's like you know you work
on tv love that's like me saying i'm not
going to rihanna's underwear yeah i mean
i'm not invited yeah you know what i'm
saying and it was a funny joke and i
think there is history there
but the fact that will felt the need to
act
it shows how a woman who has a face like
thunder which jada just seems to be set
on autopilot
um
can influence a man into doing something
extremely dumb that's not taking
responsibility away from will but
clearly he was influenced by her and
anyone who wants to act like he wasn't
it's crazy
yeah and this is the sad thing is i feel
like i'm watching a man who had the
world by the balls
and when you pair that up with a
negative draining woman you see
decades can go by and that young kid
who's full of life who seemed to have
everyone and everything he wanted
can just be sucked to [__] death you
know what i mean and now i'm looking at
him thinking
you've gone from someone who i admired
so much as one of the most
multi-talented people in the industry to
a clown who's
on stage hitting people
for yeah it was a bad joke
but you go out and take the piss back
you humiliate him you big brother him
you
intimidate him you don't strike him in
front of in front of the world and and
then
like this is someone who is a peer of
yours someone who deserves that respect
of what his job is which is to make fun
of the rich celebrities this isn't the
first time this has ever happened it
certainly won't be the last what are you
doing my point of the back of that is
there are plenty of comedians out there
who i think will smith doesn't get up
and slap you're not you know it yeah you
know and it's kind of weird because i
mean the whole it's not a coincidence
that ricky gervais was trending right
that night because the whole world was
like you ain't doing that ricky gervais
and not because ricky gervais is
particularly physically intimidating but
he would annihilate you literally he
said you didn't get near him in that
regard i do think it's kind of weird
because like you said chris rocker's got
more status than probably he's given
credit for in this situation he's
probably more
how can i put it like
he's more real relevant than will smith
has been for quite a while because he's
he is a a commentary guy he he literally
does stand-ups where he talks about
real-world situations and a lot of that
is self-deprecating a lot of that is
making he literally made a show called
everyone hates chris to show her what a
silly upbringing he had and how hard it
was being him growing up he's not i'm
the big movie star and that is exactly
how will smith conducted himself in that
exactly scenario and a lot of people
were like if the rock was presented
would you have got up no if ricky
gervais was you wouldn't have got up so
the fact that will smith
is a bully in this scenario who who
can't laugh at himself and i mean yeah
she's got a a condition but if it was
cancer i'd completely understand um you
know what i'm saying
does that make sense like now people
might say now this is typical of
lawrence at this point
there's still um i'm not saying that in
cancer is in no way funny right no but
it's a much more serious it's a much
more serious condition
anything providing everyone is in on the
job
exactly and and this is partly where it
but but but what i'm saying is if he was
worrying that that condition
that caused him to lose her hair was
going to kill her i'd understand him
being on edge and i'd understand an
overreaction but
alopecia is not that so ironically a
clip has literally came out of him of
him making fun of a bald guy
whatever whatever he's made fun of a
bald guy before how many times did he
make jokes about uncle phil's head and
all of that like
come on right now now i get that but
this is kind of this is the weird
society we live in now where why do we
have like
why do we have to unpack this to because
being offended makes you right right and
that's kind of my point here is being
offended and i get it allegedly there
are plenty of people out there who have
alopecia who will feel i don't know why
you feel upset uh that chrisrog is not
really making a joke about bald people
he's making a joke about
your ability to play someone in a film
after that it's it's a really very
nebulous joke to to get to also her
alopecia
you can see her hairline clear as day
like there are people with far worse
alopecia out there and i get that and so
we're even gonna go there minimizing
someone's condition i get it but at the
same time for me this was very much just
because i haven't got a you don't have
alopecia you just choose to shave it
sorry so that's sort of a choice of
history if anything you're much closer
to amber rose than you are to jada well
i'm a [__] so yeah right and you have a
beautiful body
yes definitely but my point is i i saw
someone who's in a relationship where
they don't
people do crazy things in relationships
where they aren't 100 in control and
don't know where they stand
and there's a bit of a power struggle
going on between those oh yeah the main
reason being i and i thought it was a
funny meme where they were like she just
looked at him and went to puck would
have done something about this and he
was like oh i'm up i'm on that stage no
and then the next meme down is like he's
like tupac would have shot him
she publicly admitted she [__] another
guy right absolutely for those who want
up the date they took a guy in who was a
struggling artist
and she called it an entanglement she
[__] the help basically she she [__]
she [__] a guy that allegedly will was
trying to help himself
in their home mentor
and this is the thing is like you know
that drake meme where it's like
and then like that that so you had the
drake meme of like call my wife bold or
whatever that's not on shock my wife all
good do you know and that's sort of i
think we've seen a very dysfunctional
relationship spill out but i also think
we've seen a man who's who has for you
for decades not years decades been on
top and for the last five years felt
like a joke felt humiliated felt like
the whole room was laughing at him felt
like everyone was saying oh his wife
[__] on his behind his back and all of
that and that that outburst was not in
any way about this [__] silly little
joke about j.i this was an outburst of
i'm sick of people laughing at me i'm
gonna do something about it and i've got
no doubt and the there's another camera
angle came out where after he slaps
chris i don't know if you've seen it you
can see jada laughing yeah
yeah and that just shows like that she's
laughing because she's wanted that she
and
she is just such a bad person like so no
wonder she played a bad guy in that
crappy gotham series do you think she'd
play a bad guy in gi jane probably a
good guy this is the thing i i remember
when he met her and she was that fresh
face girl on the fresh prince and all
that she looked she looked cute she
looked happy she looked nice but
i'm a big believer and i've seen this as
certain people get older and i've seen
women especially
in their 40s and 50s the miseries and
they have win with inside
it starts showing on their face and tony
blair is the best example because he's
becoming the green goblin i don't know
how it's happening he was actually a
decent guy when he was younger he looked
happy you could see the life in his head
you press that button that kills all
those innocent people it shows right not
on george bush's face because he doesn't
even realize what he's been doing
absolutely
and i think obama might have some sort
of like deal with someone yeah but this
is the thing
it shows on her face she is
resting [__] face is her automatic
saying right but this is what's
interesting about the whole situation
this situation shows the lens that
people look upon pop culture with so
however people choose to approach it is
kind of partly their lens onto the world
some people went this is a racial thing
you know this is a black guy slapping a
black guy
how do we see that some people say well
if you want just one at a time if mel
gibson goes up there and slaps chris
rock the world erupts that he would have
been arrested on the spot right to be
fair mel gibson has previous events
all right bad example yeah
but the point is is like i actually
thought i thought it would have been
if if chris rock slips it bangs the left
hook in or something like that right
that's what you were expecting well i
would have loved them to say that
because that then changes this whole
situation some people did say by the way
there was a moment where chris rock can
see like you can see in his eyes
considers unloading like a comedy clip
on will just sort of being like hey it's
march but imagine if this happened in
august like that sort of thing just to
start this off we've been insane yeah
and mendes will get back up like does he
go oh wait a minute yeah that that was a
tricky one because i think we'll
that whole scenario played out as good
as humanly possible for will and for the
oscars if chris hits him back
will can only lose because even if he
struggles to deck this kid on stage or
gets hauled off of him
it's chaos it's mental
has he accepted and i think there was a
level on the way up he
considered the outcome and that's why
you say like he slaps him a bit like a
girl will's got quite a feminine it's
quite a weird he does have he's always
had that kind of quite um he's got quite
big movements yeah and they aren't
always like it was very like feminine
and like there's been always shifted
like there's been rumors about will's
femininity let's just you know really oh
yeah there's there's a there's that's
part of why that kind of makes me like
him more there's that's part of why
people suspect she has
license to thrill open relationships oh
they call it i mean how open it is i
think
at some point it became open but someone
obviously is a mutual choice someone
opened that door first and we don't know
who it was but the the point is is one
of them probably did the dirty on the
other one right and i always assumed it
was will
because of the way jada dressed him down
on that podcast and he took it like a
[__] in the way he did he didn't fight
he didn't stand up for himself he just
sort of lay there and there's the memes
of him just sort of defeated which is
and i felt like a lot of people kind of
come to the that's interesting a
conclusion of
he
brought this on himself and that's why
she feels like punishing him punishing
him and punishing him for it in the way
she cut his nuts off i did feel it was
strange the way they did it publicly and
i never understood the
public humiliation it clearly wasn't
what he wanted to do it clearly was
heard
that he's
broken that did not look and like an
experience that he was
enjoying
do you have to enjoy every experience
like this is part of it does he have to
enjoy public humiliation and is it
a good thing if maybe they need to
acknowledge it publicly but that he does
look broken in public but you know jay z
and beyonce
so let's look at his behavioral patterns
in previous years
he did a book tour that we went to we
went to a private uh like concert thing
yeah he ignored her completely didn't
mention her at all not once if that's
the next book if he was
wanting people to know everything about
their relationship on his own events he
would have brought it up he would have
talked about he didn't he left it but
when he was in a room with her i don't
think he had a choice in the matter and
that's why on his face
it's the defeated poor like we're
looking at him like god you used to be
the fresh [__] prince of ballet what
has she done to you bro and this let
this be a lesson out there to men and
women
careful who the [__] you choose to spend
the rest of your life with because you
can go from a fresh face prince of pele
to an idiot on stage smacking people
because your relationship is so
dysfunctional [__] up that's part of
it and
sometimes to solve dysfunction
i think people think to go deeper into
the dysfunction helps i i felt straight
away that he thought i don't want to be
in a car with her tonight not having
acted on this and be listening to her
talking about out the side of her neck
about [__] you didn't do this
that's wrong
let let's not act like women don't do
this to men they [__] do that's a
rough skill but that's wrong though
isn't it what what she would have done
to will is it's not his risk i mean
whilst it is their responsibility
they're they're clearly in public a
married couple it's an abusive
relationship it's not a good thing that
he
would have felt pressure from her to get
up there and do something that is
technically illegal we're living in a
society and i'm sorry to say those words
but we are
we're living in a society right so far
you've nailed this where we're raising
awareness for
some of the the the violence that women
go through rightly so you know it's
about [__] time obviously but
unfortunately
manipulation
mental emotional abuse emotional abuse
is something that is very difficult to
put a finger on and to prove and to and
and often it only is um
found out about when it's too late when
one of the people has snapped or
eventually physical violence becomes um
you know it becomes into the
relationship and i i feel like that's
kind of what we're seeing with those two
is is a and i'm not saying will's
you know being abused on a regular basis
no and i'm also not saying he's not
playing a part in it because clearly he
is because he's not exempt from this at
all but i'm just saying
that
in many relationships we see
i have seen through first-hand
experience men who i know who have been
emotionally abused and have then reacted
in ways where you're like i knew that
guy five years before that he would have
never done that and now because his
woman's like are you going to let him do
that you know right
people who are known for yes are acting
in a way that's [__] mental yeah so i
personally think that there's a hint of
that in this situation at the very least
a hint i think i agree and but then
there's other there's other things going
on that we just don't know about right
yeah there's other layers and the
problem is
they've once you slapped chris rock on
stage you open that pandora's box for
people to speculate about your life and
to a huge extent right when they did
that when they did that interview uh
between the two of them they also opened
that box for people to then oh no no
this is this is all their fault this is
the yeah all of the people laughing at
will would not be laughing at will
because he let his wife [__] on it but
you know that do you know the strange
thing about it is will had that very
much had that status in hollywood for me
at least maybe i was too young to
realize for me of
i don't really care what your private
life is i just want to see your films
there are some people where you go you
didn't need it right who knew exactly
she needed she because she was
irrelevant so she had to make a show
about their lives and she she basically
thought how do i become relevant again
in this space because i'm some [__]
gotham b level actor and nothing is a
good tv
gotham's bang average right but the
point is
to be plus she wasn't even the main
character she was just a beat you know
just just one of the one of them you
know what i mean and if you look at all
of her roles you go back it's been years
since she had an involvement in a
tupac's girlfriend was the last good
role she had literally she's not a
[__] she's not an a level like that
he was so how does she get close
this guy you know the thing we've not
said once you won an oscar he won a
[__] awesome underwear
which they're now thinking of taking off
of him because of this [__] what no yeah
they really are
yeah i mean the guy insulted someone on
[__] stage at the oscars so he didn't
press charges yeah but it's not up to
him it's up to the academy i say keep it
or whatever regard regardless the point
is she needed that and he he did that so
in order for her
to grow
jada
she was willing to diminish will and now
the
the the the thing that we thought of him
as is bad boys king of dixlingen the
ladies man she annihilated it she ruined
his his perception and it doesn't matter
because it was never reality he was a
married man or whatever you thought he
was doing no but he was a demigod in
there but she she she ruined it to
elevate her status do you understand and
but did he let her
he did and that was a trade-off for
whatever had gone on between them two
beforehand and i can only assume
he hurt her and she was like you want to
make this right with me
i want you to come on the show and talk
we'll talk about it jay-z this [__] yeah
and when he brought up the august thing
you could see she was angry at him for
even bringing it up as if to say how
dare you bring it up now
if you
have a woman
you got a relationship that you bring
this young kid into the [__] house
you're trying to help him and she [__]
him and you haven't even got the right
to bring it up and she's bringing you on
this show that shows how [__] up their
um
their relationship um is okay
to answer that then what if these two
have made a pact
that they would play out a lot of their
relationship in public and whatever
happens within that relationship
they're okay with other people seeing
and the they haven't loved them because
we know that because he ignored the
whole relationship in his own shows i
get that but maybe he did it for her
that one time and has been paying the
[__] price for it ever since because
how many rolls
big rules did he get cast in after that
all of a sudden his stock went down
kingdom was a good film but it wasn't a
big role
and simultaneously
the rock and people like that have taken
all those rules who've had them all up
because the level of respect for will
went down he was seen as a bit of a joke
i'm going to be on the next thing you
know he's doing this weight loss thing
it's like your weight loss thing is
bizarre you're will smith bro like we
don't really need you to be right
generally if you're going to lose weight
just lose weight yeah like you're not an
inf fit influencer and also you don't
need to be and also
you have more than one and i feel a bit
weird about posting [__] like that and
i'm a nobody right but and and really
i didn't need that from you i just
needed you to make more films can you
just be a movie star but that's partly
where it is this his uh what's that
thing that madonna did um kabala or
whatever it is
you know that thing like the religion
thing part of me thinks they've gotten
to that point in their lives where they
don't have enough meaning from what is
going on on a day-to-day basis so this
drama has almost manifested itself in
their lives through them not having
a real reality
one thing i do want to pick up on is
there are some people who think he was
justified in what he did some people i
think
i kind of fair enough i can kind of see
a merit in that and i i i
do you know what i mean yeah if someone
insults your girl you want to slap the
[__] i'm all about that right i'm a
big proponent of that but in in the
context if that's in my relationship i'm
in a pool who's up on this thing if i'm
she's stopping them she's
like if that's
come back
it might in my relationship that's just
a that's the other way i just turned to
her and i go you got this yourself baby
no you go are you going to stand for
that yeah get up there genuinely she's
smacking
me to do that so here's the thing though
right and we all know like lots of
different relationships handle this lots
of different ways but in a pub
if someone has a go at your check and
you want to bang them out fair play
right sure crack on i don't have a
problem with it because this is the
people but this we're at the oscars
chris rock's job is to take the piss out
of you you're multi-millionaire hundred
millionaire movie stars you know
the gig you also have the privilege
every single award show we've seen drake
on stage doing at the nba players we've
seen you know gervais do with every
everyone but people still went knowing
that ricky raiser was going to be there
year after year after year knowing that
ricky gervais is not like they turned up
and went sorry who's that for [__]
sake like literally your front row yeah
your front row and the cameras are on
you you know it's coming yeah like
i i feel like though
it does go back to the oscars trying to
be relevant the oscars used to be this
classy ceremony people used to go along
accept their award and get a 20 minute
speech and whatever it is
it's
not that anymore and frankly i think the
reason that will smith won an oscar for
king richard which was a good
performance not his all time best though
he's played better characters and
there's probably going to be people who
have more nuance better performances
this year is because we realize i don't
think will's going to get another
opportunity to win an oscar for best
male getting all done he's older he's
also he's not as prevalent or as
prominent as he used to be because like
we're fans right but also
i'm i can be a fan of someone and
critically evaluate things and like
when your skin looks that smooth at 53
or whatever he is we all know you're
having [__] done jealousy's an ugly
emotion and like this guy's skin is so
good right now it's amazing and he
looked like uncle phil a few years back
like what happened i don't know but it's
called hrt i don't know why he's doing
but anyway i actually saw a guy the
other day and i've not seen him in a
while and before i saw him he looked
like that uncle phil version and then i
saw him a couple of days ago and [__]
this guy look good and i was like you
look amazing as i saw him hugged him he
just came in literally in my ear he just
went home and replacement therapy and i
was like
okay
cool man let's get on it i was literally
like wow what the [__] he's clearly
having everything done and fairfax like
you know what i mean but it's difficult
when
you've only been that guy like i'm i'm
i'm interested to see how these people
pivot because i'm looking at the rock
now and he's getting old but the guy
looks amazing you know what i mean but
like there's only so long you can be the
sex symbol
leading man
you know what i mean there are other men
there who have transitioned quite well
like i feel like i know as much as i
and they've aged very well um
your tits are fantastic for your age
um the
barack obama is aging well now whether
whatever you think about him bombing
other countries this isn't about barack
though no but the point is he is aging
well and there are certain men within
the world who do that george clooney but
this is aging
you can see on will's face there's a lot
of
work that's been telling it's a little
puffy filler yeah i get what you mean so
did you get a feeling can i can i ask
you go on do you go jim carrey
i love that jim carrey some people
didn't give a [__] and other people were
like this is will smith you can't say
anything yeah yeah kerry was like so the
point jim carrey made was like
that just showed
everything that is wrong with hollywood
because within 15 minutes will's up on
stage crying saying you do silly things
for love and then at the vogue party
however long after you
it's like that's anyway so he's crying
everyone gives them a standing ovation
and jim carrey's like what what the [__]
like you're literally applauding a man
who just assaulted one of you lot yeah
like you you a beloved member of your
community literally yeah he should have
been escorted out of the building
immediately and when like you can't
condone like
but the fact that you realize madagascar
falls not gonna happen the problem was
chris rock was such a g in the way he
[__] just carried on laughed a slap
off and went
will smith just slap the [__] out of us
yeah anyway next award what i did like
he was clearly a little thrown by
because he went we're now going to
present a documentary
i mean an award for a documentary and i
was like the fact that that's the most
you've stumbled after that is incredible
part of me thought does he go
that's one of the biggest celebrity
things that's not a [__]
i did appreciate the the moment where
where
chris was like he was like you know i
could just [__] go at you right now
but then he was like you know what you
see his eyes you literally see him go
what a pro what an absolute pro and and
also for a small amount to take a shot
like that and just keep it going
absolutely um big old hand yeah huge
there was a part you know if like this
celebrity boxing thing was going there's
a part of me that feels like going like
will you want to pick on someone your
own size like it's annoying that you you
box will smith well i box the logs off
the cooking code the offers there
he's a small guy though like you know
what i mean like it's just it
as a bigger man
there's a certain
way to carry yourself and there's
certain things you just don't do you
can't walk
if i was going to have a youtube fight
i'm going to [__] try and pick on
someone who's half my size and that's
basically what will
would what will did and i just thought
you know like respect wise you've gone
down for me because there's certain
things you just don't do you don't
you're not proving anything you're also
making chris rock look like a [__] in
front of the world now luckily
like i think a lot of people have take
taken chris aside and actually respect
the way he just like laughed it off and
it clearly he's got a chin on him and he
you know i mean either will smith it's
like a [__] and i think it's a little
bit from column a and a little from
colin yeah and
but it just
it my respect for will smith definitely
dropped my respect for anyone who from
hit from that set who spoke out and went
i like like jim kerry who said if it was
me i'd be suing him for 200 million
dollars the next day and then he said it
just shows how spineless the entire
community is he actually said though he
ordered him right after getting the
oscar when he'd done something so shitty
and then i didn't really like the woman
who was interviewing i can't know what
her name is she's sort of annoying but
she she said then she basically tried to
insinuate you saying chris rock
spineless and he was like no he just
doesn't [__] want the hassle of
having to sue somebody with that money
and also chris rock probably realizes
the goodwill that i now have for the
next
however long in my life is infinite the
roles i'm gonna get all this other stuff
like i'm gonna be prominent for a while
and you know i'm a close personal friend
of chris we stay in the same hotel so we
were talking earlier about whether this
makes will real or fake or what what
this is showing to me
we hung around celebrities but but we
also we've hung around influencers a lot
and
every influencer can be capable of a
diva moment or whatever but but
what what you don't see
is how often it happens with some of
them like some influencers play the
every guy but off camera they spoil
brats and
what i felt like we got was a a window a
tip of the iceberg into
the real will smith and and it it it
made me go oh i thought you were totally
different to this and i've i've
misjudged you totally different yeah
yeah i didn't think i thought you would
get up on stage rip the piss out of him
maybe like give him a bit of that and be
like
oh you [__] go on apologize to her
now before beat the [__] out here and
joke about it but but what i felt like
was it we got to see the brat come out
of will the the celebrity who thinks i
can do anything say anything and walk
around like there's not a problem that
i wouldn't have done that off the top my
head i i remember
i remember going back to the [__]
wembley cup where i nearly slapped that
kid and i showed restrained because in
my head i'm like you know what we don't
need this [__]
it's a silly little winner yeah it's
just it's a silly little football day
and yeah i could slap someone and it
would make me feel good in that second
but i don't want to to ruin this for
people do you know what i'm saying
but the fact that that didn't that went
through my head
at a shitty little football event
enough [__] you know offense but you
know compared to the oscars
this is the oscars of england but the
fact that that went through my head and
i can show restrained right defending my
beautiful bride and stephen yeah um but
in all seasons how much was the jail the
fact that that never went through will
smith's head at the oscars he's front
row by the way the fact that he just
thought yeah i could just do that like
that shows to me
what reality he is living in versus
us
on his night as well because he'll
probably have been given a good
explanation whether he's going to win it
or not this is your thing his pr team
should have been waking up the next day
and going fantastic great we'll do the
press release this is great you know
you're just
you've you've just won an awesome oh no
you're [__] you [__] the biggest
night of your life right for real this
is this was his night he [__] it yeah
the whole thing [__] it because no one
is talking about the fact that he won
best oscar like best man
like no one gave a [__] and no one
because there was nothing like kings
shows are all [__]
they're all [__] they're all
popularity contests well they're
basically you have to send the judges a
rolex mostly yeah the years of of you
know al pacino and de niro on that it's
a long long long time yeah so like but
yeah it just made me think like
i just felt like
if you had a camera for some of the [__]
we've seen off camera like where
influencers have had [__] fits and that
you a lot you'd see a lot more of this
like this is not as uncommon as what
people think is that good it's
we just seen the elite level of it like
and to be fair
you don't get to a point where you can
walk on stage and accept adulation and
perform
without having a massive ego like
beyonce jay-z all of these people
jennifer lopez they are famous for
apparently behind camera being a
nightmare right kim kardashian and all
of them and occasionally we see it spill
out we've seen it spill out a bit with
kanye
another man who's been emasculated by a
woman yeah we've seen him masculation is
a huge thing
but ironically crazy yeah and a lot of
people are saying that this is toxic
masculinity from will i personally don't
think that that's what this is this is
kind of where i'm this is what i'm
talking about this lent your lens onto
the world and this is where everyone's
take on it was on twitter within 20
minutes frankly i didn't give a [__]
about most people's takes apart from
stephen tries like
apart from that i found it very weird
that people thought okay what i'm going
to do here is i'm going to attach such
an over arcing narrative this whole
thing which is either about my book my
specialist subject my degree that i've
got my like if you were part of critical
race theory suddenly this became about
critical race through if this was about
like toxic masculinity suddenly will was
toxic masculinity all these people were
lining up to cancel him for whatever
subject they specialized in so if you if
you're an influencer well i understand
what it's like to be an influencer so
you know i understand what will's going
through in that moment like everyone had
their take but it clearly was from their
perspective yeah and i just thought you
know what [__] off like i i'm the same i
i avoided it to afroday because i was
like i know everyone's coming for their
clicks and they retweets and give their
hot takes but you know and i don't
understand that i'm no better than them
in the sense that we're doing this
podcast but equally like you can only go
so far 140 characters
none of you [__] are going to go deep
enough for me to actually get interested
in it on top of that my my mind went
first to kanye west interrupting taylor
swift at the awards ceremony when he got
up that all of a sudden looks really
mild bro when you look back at that and
the media reaction the weeks of uh like
churning this out oh yeah and making
kanye west feel like he'd done he'd done
a crime no but this is the thing
stopping a woman speaking this is the
thing is kanye kanye is seeing like a
real like guy from the hood yeah
will smith isn't right
will smith um
you know like mod like there's certain
for whatever reason the media has
different levels of judgment for black
people right and this is a sensitive
subject but i think it's something that
should be
acknowledged like he he was seen as your
friendly neighborhood black guy because
we literally seen him in ballet and he
was and everything was lovely and he's
even admitted like he kind of hated that
and he felt jealous of tupac because of
the cache that he was walking around
with because he was seen as the
dangerous one the one who
is about that life you know what i mean
and that's probably why he now feels on
some weird level the need to show i'm
not that guy
yeah right and like so the media then
reacts to
certain
stereotypes in certain ways so kanye got
the treatment of this guy's from the
hood how dare you who do you think you
are this is taylor swift she's a [__]
white princess what are you doing
and
i think that's one of the reasons will
smith has gotten a bit of a pass on this
he is not being judged
what they're doing is they're maxing out
his nice guy credit card they're going
right we're going to use all of this and
we're going to give you a pass but
anything else you do you're on your own
pal and you do forget though i i think
he's there's been a few times where it
slipped out there's that other clip of
him slapping a guy at an awards ceremony
on a red carpet
well the guy tried to kiss him and and
he was like but it but it wasn't a a a
pro it was more of a like it was a
backhanded like a little
but it is quite it was kind of like you
were doing it to a dog or something like
yeah but there is there is a certain
power in doing that and that that shows
you like what i could do to you but
versus what i am doing yeah and and
if someone tried this is the difference
those the guy was being inappropriate
and invading his personal space and kind
of sexually assaulting him on on some
level i mean if you give that to a woman
it's out of a show yeah okay give that
to a woman
he just walked on stage and
bitch-slapped chris rock yeah that chris
rock wasn't invading his space he was
using words hidden back with words use
your words you used to be good at that
remember yeah you know so that's the
other aspect of this where i think you
you've got to unpack the comedian side
of it a lot of comedians right now do
feel censored a lot of comedians right
now do feel like they're coming for him
but yeah and by and like we said when we
first started the the comedians are
coming for you
running anyone who i've seen them
already andrew schultz oh right i did a
whole podcast um he started his first
five minutes of his podcast
[__] legend
the amount of
brutal jokes he told like he i think he
uh
he was he he referenced um
the the williams sisters being tennis
players and said that um jada picked its
head looked like a tennis ball going up
and down on august's dick wow like like
he he went he went there like he he went
everywhere and and you know like um
legends did august yeah like
they're all coming for him now and he's
brought this on himself when you
disrespect a legend of that community
someone who they are gonna feel like
he's one of us not only is he one of us
he's mount rushmore
you're [__] and
as much as i'm a fan of will i'm like
you got to take this medicine now bro i
get that i also think there is a degree
to which we also like it goes both ways
we have to acknowledge will's probably
also not in a great space himself and
clearly in doing that is a sign he's not
in a great space yeah so python on a guy
in a oscar award show we we've seen
violence from him and we see him tears
from him
that those two things like and the way
he was crying look i know he won an
oscar but like the guy comes off like a
manic depression right now and and i'm
sure that people need to have he needs
good people around him we know he hasn't
we look at those kids
i i like willow and i like um
they're all far too entitled and
they think that they know everything
they've literally that some of the
quotes from these kids you can see that
they're not attached to real life you
can say will isn't attached to real life
and and that's the point for me
is like whenever i hear a celebrity
chatting absolute [__] i always go oh
and i like i've i've linked you guys
videos where celebrities have talked
stuff before and i'm like reality's
coming that train is on its way and it's
coming in the station any [__] day
now and for will it happened on a night
where he was at his most confident his
most relaxed and that's where
you usually it will when you're when
your ego is swelling to a point like
denzel said yeah in your proudest moment
the devil is waiting and literally with
me it was like it was you know i'm not
saying anything anything when i when
when my downfalls have came in my life
it's when i'm at my most overconfident
when i think i'm the man sure like and
that's why you can never get to that
point someone needs to check you you
need good people around you he doesn't
have that i do think though there is an
element of um
like you said earlier on if you're if
you're the offended and you're the first
person to present yourself as the
offended person
it almost puts a full stop on what
you're saying because people go oh
they're offended they must be right so
there's a series of people just who i'm
stuck with what they do is they pivot to
victim and i get it like sometimes you
will be the victim of a joke and that
and that's absolutely fine like
sometimes you will be on the rough end
of a joke but what it does is it then
mean it somehow gives that person the
license to then do whatever they want 10
times back and say whatever they want 10
times back and in many cases by the way
twist your words or add context to those
things that the comedian's not even
aware of so it become it became
irrelevant almost that chris rock didn't
know that she had that condition because
people went oh well people with alopecia
are all offended about this i'm like i'm
pretty sure some of these people first
of all can speak to their [__] selves
and i'm pretty sure by the way that it
it's not really the worst joke he could
have made there you need to put this in
some form of [__] context here this
guy's a comedian on a stage telling a
joke
these people you can't just get up and
do whatever you want and say whatever
you want it's not open season on chris
rock because chris rock upset you for
making a [__] joke but let's be real
if chris rock didn't just take that the
way he did that could have developed
into a whole nother situation he could
have gotten his ass kicked by will smith
right oh he could it because no security
guards were [__] moving right exactly
because how many security guards are
there at the oscars who are going
there's gonna be a fight here guys yeah
i mean they're half asleep right but to
your point the culture right now of i am
the offended and therefore it does not
matter if you didn't mean to offend me
if your joke was actually a good joke if
if everything was watertight i am
offended therefore nothing you say after
this point can stop my ability to do
whatever i want to say whatever i want
and i've had a lot of conversations in
the past few years where i'm saying this
more and more
in um in modern day culture where
um i feel like it's a problem with women
actually i think just not
you know i know like whenever you
generalize you know there's always
exceptions but what i'm saying more and
more is
being hurt being upset
that that ability to just lash out and
do whatever you want is
really
immature and destructive and and what we
and obviously men do it women do it but
it gets to a point where explaining what
you meant people don't want to hear it
because they want that golden ticket
they want that ability right like
they're like no no no i don't i don't
want to know i don't want because i want
to annihilate you or i want to have i
want to do whatever i want context and i
don't want to know anything now because
i've got my golden ticket contest
gets called excusing that's a real
problem that's
yeah context and explanation is
different to excusing yeah absolutely
because you can go
a rational person
like you're right you could go look i'm
sorry you feel that way he has what i
was meaning here's why i said it and
here is you know the the genuine
explanation for it but
when someone it when it's when the
offended person has no interest in that
it's because they want to be the victim
and they want to then lash out at you
right and they're not interested in any
reasoning and that victimhood gives some
people gives some people power and i
think it gives them also comfort i think
to some yeah like
a lot of different facets but we all
know people in our lives and there's one
person i've met you know our
it seems like their entire life is just
victimhood yeah it's like can i find a
victim of circumstance and it's it's
just like nothing is their fault i'm
like [__] you're in your [__]
40s man right grow up yeah you know what
i mean what happened to you
[__] 20 years ago you you really have
had time to sort of process and evolve
you can't keep living in victimhood so
sorry i'm really getting into this now
so one phrase that i've always really
thought was quite relevant and
especially in cancer culture or if you
want to call it that is tyranny is the
removal of nuance so
you and
within that i'm sorry for that as well
bro right literally twitter is like it's
just like nuance doesn't exist right and
and that's kind of my point here is it
what that allows removing any detail
from the situation and allows the victim
to be to
become la la la la i'm going to smash
the world up now it allows yeah exactly
um but it is more like i'm going to
smash your world yeah yeah this is my
revenge yeah and i'm going to say
whatever i want about you and i'll make
as many jokes you know this is often
about though it's got nothing to do with
the person that they are pointing their
finger at in that moment and just like
chris rock this was nothing to do with
him yeah this was will smith's
backlash for everything he's been
bottling up for probably five [__]
years and it's childhood it's childish
as [__] so but that's a big that's a big
issue though because
that at that point uh these are all
human actions and to some extent people
need to
remember we're all just humans like
we're all humans guys no but you're
you're lashing out is the same as
someone making a joke about you and
everyone deserves to have a bit of uh
intent is everything and that's the
that's the problem that the nuance that
nobody wants to pay attention to because
when you
have a cruel edge to your personality
and unfortunately it's becoming
because we don't live in a world now
where people do get a stiff bang in the
face very often the cruelty amongst
anyone and everyone is more evident
because they feel like they can get away
with it i can destroy you socially
rather than physically sure um
they're not interested me it's it's not
about that anymore um
i'm gonna have to wrap this up soon
actually because uh i've got a tattoo
i've got a tattoo appointment i still go
back to the kanye west thing and i think
that's how this is going to be
remembered in years to come in that
moment it feels like the biggest news
thing ever but you look back in a few
years time and you go
yeah that wasn't really what we thought
it was in that moment no i i mean it was
a stupid silly action but i i do kanye
was right by the way
about what about beyonce she did have
one of the best music videos
and taylor swift video did not live up
to that so i i don't know
his context jayla might be the next gi
gym that she might but she might yeah i
hope not because i genuinely wouldn't go
and see that film i think he needs to
get away from her but anyway uh you know
will uh will was a dick for that i agree
yeah so you know what's weird about it
is and i'll finish on this sometimes
women are very good influences in men's
lives and they make them mature
and that's really really good you see it
in the lion king right uh when nala
comes along uh simba is matured because
he finds a girl he loves right that's
great and women can be great influencers
liking wasn't real lanking wasn't real
but it it was close
and
sometimes those things those evolutions
can go too far and become very toxic i
think that's why
yeah i think i can go the op
look we're all
we're all just influencers um we're all
influenced in our own way we're all
influencing each other and get you a
partner whether you're a man or a woman
who influences you to be the best person
that you can be and i think we're
witnessing clear evidence
that
will smith is not the person we wanted
him to be at this stage and that's on
him but it's also a clear indication of
his relationship over marriage yeah a
poor marriage um an open marriage this
was uh this was our new little series
where we were just picking a part
subject if you've got an idea for a
title and you listen to the end please
get the series title ideas in the
comments below you might have just named
our new series is this the true news
podcast or something like that no i just
i feel like we could give it something
its own snappier yeah
get creative get creative we love you
all don't forget to hit that like button
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you later